la reacción general para una reacción sn
dos se parece mucho a las reacciones sn
1 empezamos con un alumno de alquilo y
lo hacemos reaccionar con un núcleo filo
y un solvente en el producto final el
núcleo filo sustituye a nuestro halógeno
la diferencia entre una reacción sn 1 y
una s n 2 está en el mecanismo veamos
los detalles del mecanismo para una
reacción sn 2 en una reacción sn 2
el enlace que existe entre el carbono y
el halógeno está polarizado porque el
halógeno al ser más electro negativo que
el carbono jala los electrones hacia él
así que tiene una carga parcial negativa
y como el carbono está perdiendo
densidad electrónica tiene una carga
parcial positiva entonces cuando el
núcleo filo entra al mecanismo
y está cargado negativamente se sentirá
atraído por la carga parcial positiva
del carbono atacará al carbono y este
ataque ocurre justo después de que el
halógeno sale aunque en realidad ocurren
al mismo tiempo generalmente las
reacciones sn dos necesitan núcleo filos
fuertes esa es una diferencia entre s n
1 y s n 2 dibujemos el estado de
transición de lo que sucede como el
núcleo fin lo ataca al carbono a la vez
que lo ataca se está formando un enlace
y eso ocurre al mismo tiempo que el
halógeno sale
entonces al mismo tiempo que el
halógenos sale por eso puse un enlace
parcial para el halógeno así es nuestro
estado de transición para una reacción
sn 2
el enlace entre el núcleo filo y el
carbono se forma al mismo tiempo que el
enlace entre el carbono y el halógeno se
rompe observen que el núcleo filo ataca
del lado contrario a donde se encuentra
el halógeno este es el único lugar en
donde puede atacar no hay forma de que
el núcleo filo ataque en el lado derecho
donde se encuentra el halógeno para este
ejemplo el núcleo filo solo puede atacar
por la izquierda el lado opuesto al
grupo saliente y por esa razón solo
podemos obtener la inversión de la
configuración
solo inversión esa es otra diferencia
con respecto al s n 1 que sólo
obtendremos la inversión al inicio el
halógeno está del lado derecho y al
final el núcleo filo termina del lado
izquierdo ese es el único producto que
obtendremos en una reacción sn 2 y por
qué se le llama sn 2
bueno la s es por sustitución la n es
por núcleo físico así que es una
sustitución núcleo física y el número 2
es por be molecular es decir que s n 2
significa que es una sustitución núcleo
física y molecular en donde la velocidad
de la reacción depende de la
concentración de dos de los reactivos
depende tanto de la concentración del
núcleo filo como del allure o de al kilo
entonces
queremos escribir la ley de la velocidad
para este mecanismo la velocidad es
igual a la constante de velocidad k por
la concentración del alumno de alquilo
por la concentración del núcleo filo por
eso es una reacción sn 2 en el estado de
transición
necesitamos del núcleo filo y del
halógeno esa es otra diferencia con
respecto al s n 1 recuerden que en una
reacción s n 1 la velocidad sólo depende
de la concentración de la luz del kilo
ahora veamos un problema sobre el
estéreo química en un mecanismo sn dos
empecemos con un alumno de alquilo como
éste pondré un grupo metil por aquí
y un grupo estilo hacia nosotros ch2 ch3
ahí está y lo hacemos reaccionar con
hidróxido de sodio n a más o menos vamos
a ver cuántos carbonos hay en nuestro
alumno de al kilo aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 y
el bromo está unido al carbono 2 así que
esta molécula es 2 bromo butano
ok y ahora pensemos en la stereo química
este carbono es nuestro centro quiral
ahora asignemos la prioridad de los
grupos unidos a nuestro carbono quiral
el bromo tiene el número 1
el grupo de tilo es el número 2 el grupo
metilo es el número 3 y el hidrógeno es
el número 4 pero podemos ignorarlo si
nos vamos a encontrar reloj podemos
darnos cuenta de que es una
configuración s así que el nombre iupac
de esta molécula nos queda como ese 2
bromo butano ahora veamos el mecanismo
sn dos identifiquemos al grupo saliente
es el bromo y el núcleo filo debe estar
cargado negativamente es una unión en
este caso nuestro núcleo filo es el
hidróxido este hidróxido atacará al
carbono y como el bromo todo
no se va de la molécula el o h tendrá
que atacar por el lado contrario a donde
está el bromo verdad
justo ahí dibujemos el estado de
transición para este mecanismo
el h formará un enlace al mismo tiempo
que el bromo esté saliendo así que
dibujamos en las heces parciales
y finalmente el bromo se va estos
electrones se van con el bromo dibujemos
lo que nos queda
el h termina del lado izquierdo ahí está
y el grupo de tilo a una estancia
nosotros lo representamos con una cuña
el hidrógeno queda lejos
y el grupo metilo se encuentra en el
plano es una línea recta
nombremos al producto aún tenemos 4
carbonos 1 2 3 y 4 y el grupo h está
unido al carbono 2 entonces es un 2
butanol y cuál es la configuración de
este carbono este es el centro final
asignemos las prioridades el oxígeno
tiene la prioridad más alta así que es
el número 1 después está el eti y
después el metil al final está el
hidrógeno pero podemos ignorarlo si nos
vamos en la dirección de las manecillas
del reloj
tenemos la configuración
así que tenemos el r2 butanol ese es
nuestro producto y como pueden ver
obtuvimos la inversión de la
configuración empezamos con el s2 bromo
butano y terminamos con la configuración
r y este es nuestro único producto por
la vía sn 2 hagamos otra vez el mismo
problema pero ahora se los dibujaré como
suelen ponerlo en un examen es muy
probable que no se los pongan como
arriba sino más bien de esta manera así
es como lo verán en un examen una vez
más identifiquemos primero al grupo
saliente y luego al núcleo filo como ya
sabemos que es una reacción es n 2 el
núcleo filoso lo podrá atacar a este
carbono del lado contrario a donde se
encuentre el halógeno así que cuando el
o h que es el núcleo fi lo ataca al
carbono
hay que hacerlo del lado contrario a
donde se encuentre el bromo el bromo
sale y él lo h forma un enlace como el
bromo antes estaba hacia nosotros
entonces él o h queda lejos de nosotros
ocurre la inversión de la configuración
por eso nos queda
r2 butanol en una reacción es n 2
siempre habrá inversión de la
configuración muy bien quiero que veamos
el efecto que tiene la estructura de un
alumno del kilo en la velocidad de la
reacción pondré dos moléculas por aquí
serán dos alumnos de al kilo
por acá está el grupo metilo y por acá
tenemos dos hidrógenos esta es una
posibilidad clasificamos el alumno de
alquilo en términos de su estructura
este carbono el que está unido al
halógeno también está unido a otro
carbono así que es un alumno de alquilo
primario ok dibujaré otro por acá en
lugar de que tenga hidrógenos abajo le
pondré grupos metilo
así que hay un grupo metilo hacia
nosotros y otro lejos de nosotros ahí
está como clasificarían a este alumno de
alquilo bueno hay que saber a cuántos
carbonos está unido este carbono
aquí tenemos 1 2 y 3 es un alumno de
alquilo terciario digamos que estos
alumnos de alquilo reaccionarán por la
vía sn 2 dibujemos al núcleo filo aquí
está formando un enlace con el carbono
el núcleo filo atacaría de este lado
verdad ahora en cuál de las dos
estructuras será más fácil que el núcleo
filo ataque bueno es más fácil que el
núcleo filo ataque en el ejemplo de la
izquierda porque no hay mucho que se
interponga en su camino es decir estos
hidrógenos son átomos pequeños que no
implican mucha dificultad histérica
mientras que en el otro ejemplo tenemos
enormes grupos metilo y gran dificultad
estética por arriba y por abajo aquí
será más difícil que el núcleo filo
forme un enlace con el carbono hay alta
dificultad es teórica lo escribiré
esta molécula no reaccionará fácilmente
en una reacción por la vía sn 2 por lo
tanto una luro del kilo con baja
dificultad es teórica así como un núcleo
filo fuerte favorecerán una reacción del
tipo s n 2 entonces una luro de alquilo
metilo será el más rápido en reaccionar
por la vía sn 2 seguido por una luro de
alquilo primario como en este ejemplo
reaccionará más rápido que un alumno de
alquilo secundario que a su vez
alquilo terciario por la vía sn 2
así que tomen en cuenta la dificultad
estética cuando hagan reacciones por la
vía sn 2 veremos más sobre esto en los
siguientes vídeos